[music]
>> Hey all, I'm Paul Reese and I'm the
developer relations lead for robotics at
Google DeepMind.
For those of you that don't know me, I
would generally describe myself as a
maker. Whether it's something low-tech
like gardening and woodworking or more
advanced projects involving the Internet
of Things and complex machines, I've
always preferred doing things in the
real world, which is why I'm very happy
to be able to tell you about all the
work we're doing in robotics here at
DeepMind.
All right, so typically AI has existed
within the digital realm. It has been
amazing for things like editing text,
analyzing massive data sets, or writing
code. But the physical world is a whole
other beast.
For a robot, understanding that a
discoloration and reflection on the
floor is potentially a spilled liquid or
figuring out the exact trajectory needed
for mapping a busy factory has
historically been a massive challenge.
DeepMind has been working to bridge that
gap by using Gemini models to move from
static chatbots to physical agents.
We aren't just teaching machines to see
the world, but we're enabling them to
perceive it with advanced spatial
awareness and understanding.
We want robots that can navigate
unstructured and messy environments
rather than only predictable and
organized scenes while being able to
interact naturally with humans and
perform complex tasks.
Okay.
That's all good, but anyone can say that
they're doing great things. So, let's
actually look at this in more detail.
In robotics, we usually follow a
perceive, plan, actuate flow.
Google's vision language models are
perfect for those first two stages,
including the latest version of Gemini
robotics embody reasoning or ER 1.6.
Unlike a general LLM, the ER model is
fine-tuned on robotics data,
specifically for spatial reasoning and
understanding to essentially be the
logic unit of the robot system.
To give you an idea of what this
actually looks like in practice, let's
look at some of the capabilities.
First, there's 2D pointing and object
localization.
The model is exceptional at identifying
points on objects, specific parts on
objects where you may want to grasp
them, and general labeling, or giving
the model a list of objects to look for
by their state, such as on desk or
closed, and having it identify those
objects based on their unique states.
What's great about this is that it's
easy to get started with our Python SDK.
You can initialize the client, pass in
the model ID for the latest version of
Gemini Robotics ER, your prompt
requesting the objects that you're
looking for, be it specific items or
more abstract requests like the
screwdriver I need for the specialty
screw, and any additional Gemini
configuration items, like temperature or
thinking level, to get a response that
you can use in your robotics project.
All right, so let's look under the hood
for a second. If you've worked with
computer vision before, you've probably
used a model like YOLO that was trained
on fixed data sets like Coco or
ImageNet.
Those are fantastic for what they are,
but they are closed vocabulary, meaning
they can only identify a predefined list
of objects.
If you need your robot to find a
particular tool for cutting a dovetail
joint when woodworking,
but that wasn't in your training data
set, you're pretty much out of luck.
With Gemini Robotics ER, we've moved to
a vision language model or VLM
architecture. When you use the generate
content method in the SDK, you aren't
just running a classification script.
The model uses semantic grounding to
locate whatever you describe in natural
language.
Because language and vision are mapped
in the same space, the model doesn't
need a specific label for every object
in your warehouse.
This is called open vocabulary object
detection.
You can ask for the tool that looks like
it's been used the most, or the
component that is currently overheating.
The model reasons through the visual
data to ground those abstract concepts
into precise coordinates.
For developers, this is a massive win,
as it eliminates the need to build,
label, and maintain custom vision models
for every unique environment. Now, the
reason we call it embodied reasoning
instead of just a vision model is
because it understands the physics of
the scene, not just the pixels. In
traditional robotics, if you told a
robot to clear the table, it might try
to pick up a dish that's far too heavy
for it, potentially stripping a gear or
dropping the plate, because it doesn't
understand weight or structural
integrity.
Gemini Robotics ER has what we call
physical common sense. When it looks at
a scene, it isn't just trying to
identify the plate and the food, but
it's reasoning about the relationship
between them.
It knows that to move a dish, it must
first move food into smaller containers
that could be lifted, or request human
intervention.
It also understands that a glass bottle
is fragile, while a plastic one isn't.
This reasoning layer allows the robot to
handle unseen scenarios, like knowing it
shouldn't try to lift a table that is
obviously bolted to the floor.
It's this kind of practical intuition
that has historically been a nightmare
to script manually.
Beyond physical common sense, there's
semantic reasoning.
One of the hardest things for an
AI-backed robot to navigate isn't
necessarily a messy environment, but
rather a vague human prompt.
If we tell a robot, "Hey, put this
away."
it's suddenly trying to figure out what
is this, and where is away.
The Gemini Robotics ER 1.6 model excels
at navigating this ambiguity.
It uses the visual context of the
environment to make an educated guess.
If it sees someone holding a
screwdriver, and there's an open toolbox
nearby, it reasons that a way likely
means that specific tray through the use
of the model's thinking capabilities.
For developers, this means we're
spending less time writing brittle if
else statements for every possible edge
case, and more time defining the actual
high-level goals for your robots.
Now, typically when we use these models,
we think in terms of snapshots, like
sending one image to generate content
and getting one answer.
But robotics is inherently a temporal
problem. So, we need to think about what
happened 10 seconds ago in order to
solve what we need to do now.
Because Gemini Robotics ER 1.6 is built
on the Gemini 3 Flash backbone, it
natively supports video and multi-image
inputs.
This allows for what we call long
horizon temporal reasoning.
Instead of asking, is the door open?
You can pass a sequence of frames from
the robot's journey through a facility.
And because the model tokenizes these
frames chronologically, it can reason
about state changes.
For example, you can prompt the model
with something like, "Look at the last
30 seconds of video. Did the gripper
successfully secure the object, or did
it slip?"
The model isn't just looking at the
final frame. It's looking at the motion
and delta between frames.
This is a game-changer for success
detection.
In the past, you'd have to write complex
heuristic code to check if a task was
completed.
Now, you can simply use the model as a
temporal supervisor that watches the
robot's work and confirms that the
physical state of the world has actually
changed in the way that you intended.
Reasoning gets us 90% of the way there,
but sometimes the visual input is pretty
difficult to process.
One issue we see fairly regularly with
standard Gemini is that images sent to
the model may not be that great for
determining what's in it due to size,
rotation, clutter, or really a variety
of other factors.
We've addressed this by adding support
for a Gentic vision to the Gemini
Robotics ER 1.6 model.
By enabling the code execution tool with
the SDK, the ER model can now generate
code for intermediate steps, allowing
the models to manipulate those images
itself to get a better understanding of
content.
Let's take a look at an example.
Say you have a production line that
makes circuit boards, and one of the
steps involves taking the unique ID off
of a certain chip to record it, such as
the ESMT chip in this image.
With traditional LLMs, this text might
be difficult to read, or it could get
mixed up with other text on the board.
By enabling the code execution tool,
Gemini writes the code to take the
image, locate the chip that you're
looking for, and then crops the image
down to just the necessary area.
In this particular example, the chip and
text are still upside down. So, the
Gemini Robotics ER model does one more
step with its generated code to rotate
the intermediate image into a more
readable orientation, making it far more
likely to correctly get the numbers off
of that chip.
The usefulness of this feature extends
far beyond just reading text, as Gemini
Robotics ER has been optimized for the
common task of reading analog gauges and
understanding common environments, like
factories and plants, to detect
anomalies.
If you have a robot running around a
facility, you can have it checking
pressure gauges, making sure doors are
properly closed, looking for spills or
snow on the ground, or performing any
number of other tasks with the same
simple tooling.
Once the robot perceives what's around
it, we can move into the planning stage
through task orchestration.
Think of this like giving a robot a
toolbox of functions. In your code, you
can provide the model with a list of
specific operations that your robot can
perform, like open gripper, move to
coordinate, detect objects, return to
home, or really anything else.
When you give the robot a high-level
task, like put the blue block in the
orange bowl, the Gemini ER model will
break that task into a series of smaller
task to plan out the entire operation.
It looks at the scene, identifies the
blue block and the orange bowl, and then
determines what order the functions
should be called to open the gripper,
move towards the block, close the
gripper, move it over to the drop-off
zone, open the gripper, and then return
to a neutral pose.
Along with high-level orchestration, the
Gemini Robotics ER model can handle
micro planning, like coming up with
trajectories that a robot should follow.
Instead of just a start and end point,
the Gemini Robotics ER model can
generate a series of intermediate
waypoints, while also highlighting ways
to avoid obstacles. So, the final part
of the perceive, plan, actuate loop, as
you can probably guess, is actuate. This
is where the gripper meets the object,
so to speak.
In robotics, actuation is just a fancy
way of saying that we're moving the
hardware, usually by sending specific
values to actuators, or motors and
joints, that make the robot go.
Now, I know the tendency is to say,
"Look at this amazing AI feature that
should change everything." But, in
traditional robotics, if you have a
machine in a factory repeating the exact
same motion 10,000 times a day, standard
control theory works just fine.
But, there are so many scenarios that
people are exploring now that aren't in
a controlled environment as they branch
out into the real world.
This leads to environments that are
messy, full of objects the robot has
never seen before, and situations that
weren't in the original training data.
For example, a robot rolling down the
street trying to deliver food could
encounter everything from a junky free
couch blocking the entire sidewalk to a
flock of unyielding grumpy Canadian
geese.
To help solve this, we've introduced our
vision, language, action, or VLA models,
including the flagship Gemini robotics
model, which is currently available
through our trusted tester program.
These models map camera pixels and
natural language instructions directly
to blocks of motor values.
You give it a prompt like, "Clean up the
desk." and the VLA streams camera frames
to determine exactly how the actuators
should move to get the job done.
This can even be used in conjunction
with the Gemini robotics ER model to
take a video of a larger task and break
it into individual parts for actuation,
letting the robot solve a series of
smaller problems to complete the big
one.
What makes this special is that we've
built these VLAs on top of the
state-of-the-art Gemini backbone.
Because the model has a massive general
understanding of the world, the robot is
able to understand context and details
about the objects.
For example, when we gave our robot a
small basketball and a net game and
asked it to do a slam dunk, the model
was able to take the ball and place it
through the hoop despite not being
previously trained for this.
Beyond simple pick-and-place operations,
we're also pushing for true dexterity.
We want our machines to do more than
just move around, but we're training our
models for complex tasks like plugging
in cords or performing fine detail
precision operations on a workbench.
Finally, we've taken a generalist
approach to embodiments.
Whether you are working with a humanoid,
a quadruped, or a mounted bipedal setup,
our goal is to meet you where you are.
These models are designed to be
embodiment-agnostic,
providing a powerful, general-purpose
brain that can be adapted to whatever
hardware you're working with.
By combining the high-level reasoning of
the ER model with the reactive,
real-time control of the VLA, we're
closing the loop on truly autonomous
physical agents.
All right, so at this point we've gone
over the tools for the full perceive,
plan, and actuate loop. But, that's
really just scratching the surface.
The next big question is how do you
actually talk to the robot? And how does
the robot keep you in the loop?
For example, if you have a humanoid
robot, people will likely tell it things
like hello and thank you. But, there's a
lot of variants in how they might say
these.
If your robot isn't programmed for each
variation, it could get kind of awkward
as it stands there and just feels
unnatural. But, with additional tooling,
the work for smooth human robot
interactions could be handled for you.
To accomplish this, I'm a big fan of the
Gemini Live API.
This is what turns a robot from a
pre-programmed machine into an
interactive partner.
It enables low latency bidirectional
conversation between you and the Gemini
model,
letting you give instructions through
natural language, like saying, "That
screw looks a little loose. Can you
tighten it?"
On top of that, this isn't just about
audio. The Live API allows you to stream
camera frames directly to the model,
providing constant visual context.
This helps you create feedback loops
where you can use this stream to even
alter plans during runtime.
Where the real magic happens though is
through function calling. Based on what
the model hears and sees, it can decide
to trigger a specific developer-defined
function.
This is the bridge that allows a natural
conversation to turn into precise
physical action, opening the door to
incredibly fluid human robot
interactions.
And while you're planning out your
builds, having a playground to test your
logic is definitely a nice to have. And
that's where AI Studio comes in.
This lets you rapidly prototype prompts
and test how the model perceives images
from your specific hardware without
having to constantly re-flash or reload
scripts on the robot.
Along with this, one of my favorite
areas is the build section.
We've actually created a few web app
templates to show off what's possible,
like integrating the MuJoCo simulation
engine directly into the browser. Like
you can see here, where we're running a
virtual robotic arm that uses the Gemini
Robotics ER model to detect block
locations, then performs a pick and
place task based on that information
without the risk of testing on real
hardware, really lending itself to a
fail-fast, fail-safe strategy.
And to wrap up this whirlwind tour of
Google DeepMind's robotics offerings,
let's talk about safety.
In the digital world, if an AI
hallucinates, it might give you a weird
recipe or a buggy snippet of code. Not
ideal, but you know, not catastrophic.
When this happens in robotics, we're
talking about real-world hardware,
sometimes with significant weight,
potentially moving around in the same
space as people.
As we all probably know, tools like a
simple table saw deserve respect because
of the physical risk involved.
When you add an autonomous brain to a
machine, that respect for safety has to
be built in from the ground up.
This is why our team is engaged in
ongoing safety research to develop a
holistic approach to robot protection.
We like to think of it as the Swiss
cheese model of defense. No single layer
is a perfect barrier, but by stacking
multiple layers of safeguards, spanning
the semantic, physical, and operational
aspects of safety, we can effectively
mitigate risk.
To evaluate these layers, we've
introduced the Asimov safety benchmarks.
As discussed in our research, these
aren't just theoretical. They are
grounded in reality using the NEISS
or National Electronic Injury
Surveillance System database.
This contains real-world injury reports
from hospitals to teach the model about
physical common sense.
Second, we ground our work in
established industrial ISO standards to
ensure our benchmarks reflect the same
operational safety constraints used in
factories today.
So, that's a quick look into what we're
working on within the robotic space at
Google DeepMind. At the end of the day,
we're building tools to be your partners
in creation. So, I'm looking forward to
seeing what you all build. You can find
more information in our developer docs,
cookbooks on GitHub, and sign up for the
trusted tester program on the Gemini
robotics webpage. Thanks for listening
in, and I'm looking forward to seeing
what you build.
>> [music]
[music]